Senator Al Franken's offering a
not-so-funny farewell the man who was
accused of multiple gropings and other
stuff will resign but no apologies no
admission of guilt just accusations and
lashing out of course against President
Trump and Senate candidate Roy Moore as
predicted Franken was a victim of the PC
lynch mob but now there's a backlash
against the Ingraham angle for
identifying the real cause of his
ousting it was all a cynical political
ploy and a huge development at the
Justice Department a top official
demoted after reportedly as we thought
coordinating with the law firm peddling
that infamous anti Trump Russian dossier
but we begin with the fall of the
liberal icon comedian Al Franken and the
me - pandemic that's the focus of
tonight's angle look Franken really had
no choice after most of his Democratic
colleagues in the Senate called him to
quit called on him to quit but listen
closely to his statement today some of
the allegations against me are simply
not true
others I remember very differently think
about that for a moment he's basically
calling members of that me - movement
liars but he's unwilling to fight for
his reputation I happen to think this is
a bad decision and I pretty much don't
agree with him on anything and why did
his fellow Democrats turn on him so fast
and so furiously as we explained in the
angle last night the Dems did not
suddenly become beacons of morality
wagging their fingers at everyone else
because they're on the moral high ground
this was a crass political ploy
Democrats dumping Frank and overboard
because now that they can claim the
moral high ground for 2018 and pursue
allegations against Donald Trump and Roy
Moore so
process if you're accused and you're a
man you're dasa this Venezuela Cuba this
is every third world Banana Republic
let's not have new process let's not ask
anybody any questions let's not have any
chance to have a hearing let's just
lynch him because when we get down
lynching will be so pure we'll feel so
good
the new Puritanism in the Democratic
Party that's a switch and you wouldn't
believe the headlines we got in response
the Washington Post wrote Al Franken
finds unlikely defenders on Fox News The
Huffington Post almost identical meet Al
Franken's Republican defenders Mediaite
Laura Ingraham Newt Gingrich defend
Franken from dem lynch mob newsflash
we weren't defending Franken we were
defending the notion that one should be
considered innocent until proven guilty
you see the real story here what we were
warning you about is this it's kind of a
PC pogrom underway with a nasty
political edge to it they're dropping
like flies now former democratic
congressman harold ford jr. he was fired
today by Morgan Stanley for allegedly
several years ago grabbing a woman he
was trying to take her out to drinks a
couple of times I guess she didn't like
that and now he's vowing to sue the
woman and Morgan Stanley in response
that it never happened congressman Trent
Franks this was a bizarro one he
announced today that he's going to step
down rather than endure an investigation
for having what he called a discussion
of surrogacy with two previous female
subordinates and that's a that takes the
cake now look we need to be careful here
you myself everyone that we don't get so
caught up in the white heat of the
movement the me2 movement that lives and
careers are destroyed without much
evidence and in a flash and look they're
sure they're credible allegations out
there they're creeps that need to be
shown the door no doubt about it
but we also have to be wary of what I
call the me to flu the gender
opportunists who come out of the
woodwork with allegations many
many years later because it serves a
political or a personal end are anything
getting tired of the sudden explosion of
moral piety spewing from those who ended
up enabling the real abusers by looking
the other way because it was political
expedient to do so for years me too and
that's the angle